moving on we've talked a lot about
Republicans it's now time to talk about
some problems that the Democrats have
and it's a problem unfortunately named
Democratic senator Dianne Feinstein
this week of course it was revealed that
Feinstein has missed 60 votes her
absence from the uh senate committee is
actually preventing Biden's judicial
nominees from being confirmed they can't
move out of committee because they have
to have her vote but she's been out
since uh early March with shingles she
is now out of the hospital of course she
only spent a few days there she's been
recuperating in her home in California
she's 89 years old
she is not running for reelection her
term ends at the end of the year 2024.
and it's time for her to resign
that is my personal opinion I think it's
time for Dianne Feinstein to resign
but I'm not saying she has to resign
because of her health issue I'm not
saying she has to resign because of her
age
my plan my idea is I have a plan I have
no control over any of this my idea
is she needs to resign for the good of
the democratic party not for the Biden
judges thing
but for the House of Representatives
we got three Democrats
that are going to be running
in that Senate primary next year and
because they're running in the Senate
primary they cannot run for their house
seats
so three of those Democrats running at
least two of them obviously will lose
their seats and will no longer be
elected officials here in the United
States
and what terrifies me
are the people we could lose
we could lose Katie Porter and Barbara
Lee from the House of Representatives
that thought terrifies me I love them
both they are vital voices in that House
of Representatives we need them there
the third person running of course is
Adam Schiff
and I hate to say it but I think Schiff
is probably the shoe-in for this job
I don't want him to be the one to get it
I'd love to have Katie Porter in the
Senate I'd love to have Barbara Lee in
the Senate but I don't want it to come
at the expense of the other one having a
job as an elected official because
they're both good people
so how do we overcome that
Dianne Feinstein resigns
what happens when she resigns well
California is one of 37 states that says
if a senator resigns or you know is no
longer in office during the rest of
their term
the governor gets to appoint their
replacement until the next election
Gavin Newsom
would be able to appoint the replacement
that replacement
is the one who would most likely go on
to obviously be the nominee for 2024
which could get rid of the need for the
primary
which means we wouldn't lose those
Democrats from the house now I know
that's a weird idea because it takes
away the primary it may not I mean if
they still want a primary they can still
primary they still have the option
but it kind of solidifies you know
listen
here's what we can do
so Gavin Newsom
needs to go meet with Dianne Feinstein
they need to have this talk they need to
work this out Feinstein does need to be
a part of the the conversation my God
she has been in office she deserves to
be part of the the conversation she's
been there for so long she is an
institution
but she has also done her service and
it's time to pass that torch but that
torch has to be passed in a way that
doesn't screw over the Democratic Party
in the House of Representatives and
right now that is exactly what we're
headed towards like that's what's gonna
happen
but we can avoid that if she resigns
and Gavin Newsom can appoint that
replacement
so Gavin Newsom could say listen all
right Katie Porter
you're the senator now
which would mean obviously Katie Porter
wouldn't lose her seat
we could probably avoid a messy primary
at that point
and go from there he could say Barbara
Lee you're the senator now
that may make Katie Porter say okay look
if she's got it now clearly she'll win
the primary I'm gonna back out I'm going
to keep going on my house seat
it may not work the way that I'm
thinking you know I I could be wrong
about this this is just my idea my
theory but I think it's the best and
smartest move
let Feinstein resign on her own terms
let her have a say in what happens to
the seat I know that's not how politics
is supposed to work the people get the
choice
but for the good of the Democratic Party
we can't lose those voices for the good
of the country we can't lose both those
voices in the house we simply cannot
and this may avoid that
may not be the prettiest scenario may
not be the thing that everybody loves to
do
but I think it's the smartest path
forward at this point